un carré d'as pour le poker il ya
quelques années encore c'était un jeu un
peu sulfureux réservé aux initiés avec
whisky et gros cigare aujourd'hui tout a
changé on compte un demi million de
joueurs de poker de façon régulière en
france beaucoup de femmes
c'est devenu un jeu branché notamment
grâce à internet mais pas seulement
jean françois feer est francis forget je
suis ébéniste et je travaille c'est ce
travail d'instruction spectacle comme
les cartes
les gens ici sont mélangés autour de la
table 108 d'âge et de profils différents
leur seul point commun le poker un coup
d'oeil sur les cartes du voisin ce n'est
pas réglementaire mais bon ce soir pas
d'argent sur le tapis autre chose les
ati on parle de calcul un petit peu de
psychologie de chance de travailler sur
soi de gestion de
ce sont 113 ambiance moins convivial
dans le petit studio de sébastien de
caen 30 ans lui joue seul sur internet
depuis un an ce conseiller financier est
au chômage
le poker est devenu son gagne pain une
vraie poker si vous voulez ça commence à
dire vers 16h et donc à partir de là je
fais des petits breaks vert vers minuit
1h du matin je rejoue de deux heures
parfois 5h 6h du matin et voir des mois
où près de 400 euros
mais moi j'en perds deux premiers
jusqu'à 5000 euros les meilleurs mois
net car les gains du jeu ne sont pas
imposables en france les tournois type
las vegas ont lieu ici avenue des champs
elysées à paris au numéro 104 l'aviation
club de france
un cercle de jeux privées en fait une
association à but non lucratif elle
reverse 60% de 0,7 à l'état mais ses
jours n'étaient pas prenez vos plats
temps à démarrer
les croupiers mélanger les cartes il
vous plaît pour le droit de s'asseoir
il faut payer 250 euros 70 compétiteurs
essentiellement des hommes un seul gros
lot 6225 euros alors pas de pitié
moi je le joue comme un sport de combat
c'est bien compétition pure jean paul
renoux a 50 ans il ne vit que du poker
deux ans qu'il s'entraîne aujourd'hui
mon capital augmente de 2 à 3000 deux
trois villes de leur part est mon
objectif c'est que de gagner
suffisamment au jeu pour pouvoir me
payer ces tournois à las vegas et puis
bien sûr intégrer une équipe
professionnelle de joueur des amateurs
qui souhaitent devenir professionnel une
nouveauté en quelques années grâce au
poker
la fréquentation du club a complètement
changé on a une évolution
mais attention le poker est un jeu
d'argent avec ses dérivés ces phénomènes
d'addiction et en cas de problème un
recours devant les tribunaux est
difficile car la loi française encadrent
mal la pratique du poker
chacun est donc seul face à ces cartes